[Music]
hey you guys had to get on a diet can I
can I make an announcement here while
we're at the beginning of the show with
everybody coming in I want to really
make it very clear uh that we only got
two more weeks yeah
uh we are going to be exclusively on
Rumble exclusively on locals in the next
two weeks and I have to say uh you guys
got to go to revenge of
assist.locals.com you have to sign up
Kevin Nash's dead son
would have wanted us to have the best
locals account
um Kevin Nash's dead vampire son wants
us to be bigger than Nick he's beautiful
too he was gorgeous yeah slugging
gorgeous when he learned or dead no they
really did a video by the way
he did a video
on his show ah him and Sean Oliver did a
video Tristan wanted this Channel at
100K Subs
no he did not know is that where he's at
on Kevin Nash click this they click this
podcast yeah I even mean to get
sidetracked
Kevin Nash's dead son is gonna burn in
hell if you guys don't sign up for our
locals
with his dying breath he looked at me
and he said Dad
get that plaque I'm like are you
glamming when did his kid when did when
did his kid die yeah his dumb kid died
like two weeks ago okay so but it's one
of the less it's one of the most recent
Christmas wanted this Channel at a
hundred thousand I swear to God okay
quick quick before anything else okay
before we move on even if you don't like
wrestling this is disgusting and let me
explain why
Kevin Nash of course you probably know
Kevin Nash even if you're like if you're
into wrestling when it was cool
um
Kevin Nash was in the NWO Kevin Nash was
Diesel and Kevin Nash was also the
mighty Oz put some respect on his name
the mighty eyes he was he was uh he was
also the big man Vinnie Vegas well nice
choice oh yeah on osw they'd be like uh
so out come the bad mang and the Big
Bang
[Laughter]
I love those guys so
this is real this is real his son died
two weeks ago of of seizure and a heart
attack at 26 you know which happens a
lot lately how was I'm sorry how was
this kid 26.
[ __ ]
so he died he quit drinking man
is that really what he said that's what
he's been saying he quit drinking cold
turkeys we had a seizure and a heart
attack and died no no no no well I mean
I mean is that possible of course it is
you know what else is possible well hold
on you don't have to say I'll do it
safely so we don't get in trouble want
to see
unrelated to what we're about to play
okay this is totally different by the
way this is unrelated yeah we were just
this is Royce has an add problem
sometimes it's scatterbrain got a brain
probably because I didn't count am I
going to say it
uh myocarditis NBC News two more weeks
two more weeks we have to worry about it
anymore myocarditis after covet
vaccination Pfizer materner are tracking
adverse health effects if any if any
that may appear in years in the years
never until nights or 30 days if you get
through that you're fine now it's years
uh following a diagnosis of the vaccine
uh a vaccine Associated heart problems
so it doesn't it doesn't
doesn't it does now unrelated because
I'm a scatterbrain back to this so what
happened was that kid so is his dead son
um depending on who you ask because you
know the problem with wrestling is so
much Cafe mixed in you know he mixed in
with the truth so uh I don't know if his
son why would you work your dead kid
well no they're both maybe the dead kids
working the boys as they say we're
working the boys okay got it so then I
according to kfabe or I don't know
rumors the rumors in innuendo according
to Dave Meltzer uh his son became a
vampire and he glammed him and he was
gorgeous a gay vampire son
so he died and they have been so he did
an episode like today like the day after
his son died okay and they were doing
Bluetooth ad reads and everything and I
ran into God doing Bluetooth reads and
everything and they milked his dead son
maybe the rigor mortis reminded him
anyway I'm sorry it was the highest
watched episode of his show obviously
and it's a newer show so now they've
been milking clips and doing more stuff
about Tristan because it gets them the
most clicks so they're using his dead
son to get pity clicks to grow the
channel
so yeah they're just being brazy the
title of this video this is [ __ ]
disgusting it's two weeks
two weeks Tristan Nash wanted this
Channel at 100K that's what I mean I I
didn't know when I walked in here if
because that one was you know like I
said it was
by the way I just want to let you know
Tristan Nash wanted our Rumble Channel
at 100K as well that's why I was saying
and he wanted our locals he wanted you
guys to go to
revengeanceassist.locals.com see it's
less disgusting to for us because we
didn't [ __ ] know him like it's less
disgusting for us to do it because we
didn't even care about you dumb dead kid
it was it was bottomed out and this one
um
you could have a mic box or you could
have a Shore mic you can't have both
he's got both
I know
it's you know like the funny thing is
and
like T when he found out I don't know if
Steve told him or I don't know who took
that one who somebody told him that if
you get a a hundred thousand subscribers
that you get like that plaque
I was kidding I was kidding about the
plaque
Essie you should know by now that
by the way I wow by the way I holy [ __ ]
he really is for the black I grew I got
drunk Friday night on nightwave and did
probably an hour meltdown about this
piece of [ __ ]
forget if you like this isn't wrestling
talk this if any podcaster would have
done this right this is insanity it's
pretty gross it I mean it's pretty
[ __ ] it's not even that nice of a
plaque no it's not I can you I can get
you a free Hey Kevin right now I'll go
to AliExpress and get you a better
looking one a knockoff one you want it I
got you I'll go to Michael's and make
you one yeah [ __ ] seriously
and then I'll spray paint hardcore over
it like the hardcore belt nice yeah nice
right from I'm assuming next week he's
gonna say oh hey I had a dream about
Scott Hall and he wants us to be at home
okay it turns out he was and it was
weird man because he was in his razor
gimmick this is [ __ ] nuts I had a
dream man and it was Scott but he was in
his he actually wasn't even in his razor
gimmick he was in his gator Hunter his
early Florida gimmick man and he was his
old AWA thing
because he kept asking me how much he
wanted to [ __ ] Dixie Carter
that was like it was weird man China was
there too man she said get us to 100K
get him the plaque man so he's having a
dream of all these dead wrestlers
Owen Hart said his only regret wasn't
putting that safety harness on but it
was that he didn't get us to a hundred
thousand guys Tristan told me that much
said to him that he should uh get us to
100K Chris Benoit actually killed his
family because he looked into the future
and saw that Kevin Nash was not at 100K
turns out Chris Benoit killed his family
to save him from the vax
story man
that's why they call him Kevin Pfizer
Sullivan
me and daddy didn't get along Edgar all
the dead wrestlers
you know they say that Abdullah the
Butcher wouldn't have gotten the AIDS
had I have had 100k
that's all that's all he thought it
became a goal yeah also I like the art
behind them let's look at every Airbnb
you stay at oh God yeah you know bro
he's Airbnb art is the best he has
switched that painting like three times
because people are always smashing it in
the comments yeah it's really funny he
switched that page there's been like
three other paintings that are similar
to that one and people are always making
fun of it and he's constantly changing
the painting and like pretending like
they they read the comments like
obsessively these two so like
you know uh uh Kevin from the whole
[ __ ] show had a bunch of people just
making fun of Sean Oliver's hair one day
and then they noticed now that he's
obsessively checking his hair all the
time and stuff they may find Kevin
Nash's painting he changed the painting
it's so [ __ ] funny man
you're dead kid if you get a hundred
thousand yes he was like you know and
then I think we we I think we all talked
one night all of us when we we got done
and um
like we were all on the screen and I
think Steve was saying no I think you
get one and you could buy the other ones
and we got in the car that night and she
said well and I'll be getting one of
those I'll be getting one of those
[ __ ] you know what a vaccine
well
so so to me that's the thing you know
it's just like I have to keep this going
for as long as it takes to get a hundred
thousand subscribers because
cash on a plaque and putting that
[ __ ] in this condo he's going to
put his sons
remains in a YouTube
plaque
to put it up in his Daytona Beach condo
that is the whitest trash thing I've
ever heard in my [ __ ] life
wow you're a piece of [ __ ] Kevin Kevin I
I
Royce and I can comfortably say we've
had our most success from doing live
streaming on YouTube and all these
things
I wouldn't do that that would be so
cheap
I'm gonna put it in the plaque I'm gonna
put the ashes in the plaque frame by the
way with water and glitter so you can
shake it if you think that's bad like
the last 45 seconds of this video
is some of them all that's 45 okay
exploitive [ __ ] a little bit like you
got to go like almost to where it's
loaded no no you had to go back a little
more you'll go back a little bit more
it's it's here
um yeah maybe it's about a minute or so
but this last minute is so then Tristan
used to play music terribly
all right so we gotta compressor right
here Sean Oliver they start talking
about Tristan get all wistful and then
they he starts potting in his music very
badly I might add it just kind of Pops
in really loudly as they're going to the
end of the clip and it just just play
watch watch out watch how ghoulish this
is
wait real quick before we do that hear
me out maybe put the Ashes to some sort
of snow globe
that's classy what do you think you like
a Disney snow globe like yeah yeah yeah
one with like MGM because that's we have
the bastards the beach remember
Hollywood yeah like a bike a bike week
yeah yeah so maybe you tried to get it
in that uh iced tea container yeah let's
just try and do the exacto knife slipped
well we should tell everyone that click
this is a production of Butch and
Sundance media producing association
with podcast heat created by Kevin Nash
Tristan Nash and Shaw Oliver producer
Steve coven graphics and social media
that's his son's band yeah oh no it gets
worse okay it gets worse okay Burleson
theme song by Dale Oliver thank you for
research by Kevin have I Tristan Nash
copy imagine that technical research by
Kevin Nash uh copyright 2022 Butch and
Sundance media
can't do me a favor ask your son if we
can do another
no no we're not Don Royce
son he's getting he's talking to his dad
to his dead son no no no no no no no no
get ready I'm telling you
it's gonna get you're good you're all
gonna be so angry I'm so glad I brought
this to the show
hey T can we do another one
what's that hold on I can't hear it
this is this is bro I'm not kidding you
this is like the second worst thing he's
ever done lockdown being the worst yeah
but they can't be most of his work in
TNA really frankly King's wrestling yeah
the hair dye hair dye Nash
hey T one more song it's so hot down
here
I shouldn't have gotten that [ __ ]
Champ
hey to you let me ask you something are
you glamming me friends are not close we
get to 100K
yeah
you're
you're [ __ ] the comments have to be
some of them are not some of them are
positive believe it or not there are
some people in there going like he's
been he's been deleting comments though
for sure because there have been people
in there like what are you doing you
[ __ ] ghouls yeah he's not gonna be
able to delete the [ __ ] clip I'm
about to post on YouTube guys do it for
tea
well he did a lot of things for T Test
Trend
oh my God it goes it cuts to this right
when the song crescendos of course
you got to get that 100K man
oh no
100k with my dead Son bro two weeks it's
only been two weeks
yeah well to be fair he did get drunk
and fight his dad on Christmas so maybe
this is just his revenge remember when
they both got arrested on Christmas yeah
each other up I feel like they didn't
like each other
well
I know I just got I got everybody all
fired up now we're gonna have a [ __ ]
crazy show [ __ ] dude
Kevin Nash [ __ ] sucks Sean Oliver
[ __ ] sucks how do you how do you how
do you wreck you're gonna call a bunch
of folk he's gonna watch our clip that
we put up by the way because he watches
everything about himself you [ __ ]
morphs
don't realize I'm [ __ ] working them
yeah are you you're working on your dead
son Jesus me and T are doing it we're
doing it to pop the boys in the back
we're calamities
Jesus Christ [ __ ] Kevin Ash and his dead
kid anyway anyway moving on